[Musica]
io visto che tutti fanno un collegamento
con gli spicci precedenti io voglio fare
subito e voglio dirvi che ho preso
troppo alla lettera la nostra ingegnera
di prima e lo spezzato in due cosa
volevo tenerlo così allora io mi occupo
d'arte mi occupo d'arte contemporanea e
vorrei parlarvi di questa diffidenza che
c'è intorno all'arte contemporanea che
una diffidenza giustificatissima io
faccio mestiere ancora peggiore
dell'artista perché sapete che quando
uno vede queste opere contemporanee che
sembrano finte tende a pensare lo potevo
fare anch'io ma questo non è mica arte
ma cosa c'entra con la grande pittura
del passato
io allora oggi voglio raccontarvi perché
questa questo quadro che voi state
vedendo questa tela se volesse
acquistarla costerebbe 60 70 milioni di
euro e voglio raccontarvi voglio cercare
voglio provare a giustificare il lavoro
che faccio niente altro ne devo pur
campare e cercherò di spiegarvi perché è
una pietra miliare della storia
dell'arte e voglio collegarmi a uno
spettacolo comico che ho visto qualche
qualche anno fa dove c'erano questi
questo trio comico che andava in giro
per un museo di arte contemporanea per
prendere in giro quelli come me fa
sedere un comico sulla sedia era alto
gli fa ferma cosa fai è un capolavoro
quella non è una sedia e l'ha sottoli e
sottolineare che il che è un oggetto di
uso comune può diventare un oggetto
d'arte sei pazzo indovinato un
capolavoro vanno avanti qualche metro
questo redarguito vede un estintore di
fa guardano e meraviglia che l'opera
d'arte qui per opera d'arte favolosa e
il costone gli fanno veramente
quell'estintore del museo e fanno vedere
durante questa durante questa questo
percorso fanno vedere questo altro pezzo
binari nella nebbia
capolavoro però io voglio cercare di
spiegarmi perché questo si è perché
questo no questo sì questo no perchè
questo vale 70 milioni di euro perché
questo è una presa per il culo
cercherò di spiegarlo l'arte
contemporanea è fatta di brand è fatta
di mode e fatta di è fatta di gli
artisti che spesso vengono costruiti a
tavolino che poi siano validi o no
questo io non lo so ma io credo che sia
sbagliato pensare lo potevo fare anch'io
questo non ne arti io credo che questo
non sia giusto cercherò di spiegarvelo
oggi questo lo squalo da 12 milioni di
dollari
questo è di un artista contemporaneo
forse il più famoso artista
contemporaneo vivente si chiama demian
hirst è questo un certo punto il più
importante collezionista del mondo
charles ciacci e il più grande
gallerista del mondo larry gagosian che
negli stati uniti chiamano larry go go
per far capire quanto è bravo con gli
affari
a un certo punto decidono che questo
doveva diventare l'artista del momento e
lo costruiscono a tavolino e quindi la
gente che vanno i musei e vede un'opera
del genere non può che forse non è che
non può però capisco che si sente presa
in giro qualcuno si è spaventato e mi
chiedo scusa
però io vi voglio far capire una cosa io
ho appreso che l'arte soprattutto quella
contemporanea perché si è evoluto non è
più se non si è voluta non è più
semplicemente stile poi quello che avete
sentito prima era poco più di un urlo
un urlo quasi bestiale comunque
fastidioso che via anche spaventato
visto qualcuno saltare sulle sedie e
giustamente non ve l'aspettavate e
sgradevole però se vuoi questo urlo
inserite in un contesto lo inserite in
una storia esattamente quel secondo che
avete sentito prima
allora può diventare qualcosa di
importante può diventare qualcosa di
significativo
[Musica]
era questo
possiamo abbassare grazie
era questo era pavarotti quindi se voi
togliete a pavarotti quello che gli sta
intorno
potete anche pensare che il suo sia un
urlo disumano che si fa spaventare
persino in un teatro
e allora cosa succede succede che io
voglio partire sarò in pochi minuti vi
voglio raccontare la storia di quel
quadro nero di questo paint it black
come ho deciso di intitolare questo
questo intervento e andiamo a una parola
molto lontano e molto triste che si
chiama povero che significa devastazione
significa violenza noi lo leggiamo come
il massacro degli ebrei
inizialmente ai danni dello della russia
e della russia zarista
ed è nel 1903 proprio nella nell'attuale
lettonia che nasce marcus roth collins
che forse non vi dice niente
forse a qualcuno invece dice qualcosa il
suo nome americanizzato mark rothko mark
rothko e considerato uno dei più
importanti artisti del novecento
l'autore di quella tela cosa succede
succede che è figlio di un progressista
di un farmacista che regala in farmacia
a chi non se li può permettere ed è
costretto a emigrare negli stati uniti
si porta con sé la famiglia ovviamente
si porta con sé il piccolo mark che vive
una infanzia completamente emarginata
completamente vive solo vive male però è
un ragazzo così intelligente che
crescendo ed era una cosa non scontata
negli anni 20 degli stati uniti da
immigrato russo riesce a ottenere una
borsa di studio per gli ale una borsa di
studio per yale che non accetta non
accetta perché a un certo punto un
giorno va a trovare un proprio amico
alla artest udienza students league che
è la scuola che ha ospitato in america
alcuni dei più importanti artisti del
novecento e li impara una cosa di
capisce una cosa capisce che l'arte deve
essere la sua vita ma non un'arte
semplice alla a rothko a mark rothko
piace il teatro e sebbene volesse fare
il leader sindacale perché aveva una
certa retorica decide di mettersi a fare
l'artista è anche all'epoca anche negli
anni 30 c'erano c'erano delle mode
questa per esempio era una di quelle
modi e allora rothko forse anche
conformandosi a a queste cose e
studiando da max weber che l'allievo di
matisse cerca un suo stile fino ad
arrivare a dei quadri che hanno il
sapore di quelli di quelli di chagall
ma quello che interessa rocco e il
teatro e il teatro sono le figure che si
animano e che lui cerca di portare
sempre di più verso l'astrazione perché
non vuole che distragga quindi diventano
sempre più stilizzate sempre di più
sempre più sempre più astratte fino ad
arrivare a qua e vi dico questo quadro
qui è un record assoluto è stato venduto
da christie's nel 2012 per 90 milioni di
dollari e un quadro le norme e un quadro
gigantesco rothko viveva male viveva
viveva solo cercava al proprio stile e
lo cercava attraverso una
rappresentazione teatrale delle tele un
uso del colore che esattamente come voi
vedete qua con gli più in fondo vedono
più strati quelli davanti forse meno e
vedete prima tutto il pubblico
poi il l'avanzare del palco forse
qualcuno vede anche questo grosso bollo
rosso vedete lo schermo il soffitto
questo è quello che volevano un sipario
di luce ed è quando arriva in italia
alla cappella sistina che lui
stendendosi sul pavimento capisce quello
che vuole fare capire quello che vuole
fare perché per lui è importante che non
si stia davanti alla tela ma si stia
dentro la tela vive una vita
difficilissima alcolizzato sempre più
solo ma anche se questo tipo di
astrazione conquistano al mondo e lui
russo a un certo punto riesce a prendere
la cittadinanza statunitense e non solo
diventa il più importante
americano gli stati uniti decidono che
deve essere lui a rappresentare tutti
gli usa alla biennale di venezia la più
importante delle kermesse artistiche
internazionali nel 1958 quindi lui va va
a rappresentare gli stati uniti e si
spinge verso sempre più verso una
semplificazione verso muri di luce che
sono muri di colore sempre più grandi
vuole vuole avvolgere usa sempre più il
nero sempre più i colori scuri dice che
a un certo punto il nero teme che il
nero mangerà il rosso e il sapore della
morte mangerà mangerà la passione e lui
inizia a dire che questi quadri sono la
rappresentazione di del secondo prima
dell'attimo prima del disastro
dell'attimo prima dell'esplosione
io vi assicuro che questi quadri visti
dal vivo pulsano sono vivi che avvolgono
michelangelo antonioni che tutti quanti
voi conoscete
quando vedete un film di antonioni se un
film dura due ore poi dopo un'ora e
cinquantacinque iniziata dire quando
comincia il film ed è tra antonioni
erotico che inizia uno scambio di
corrispondenza commovente meraviglioso
finché antonioni arriva a scrivere a
rothko i suoi quadri sono come i miei
film parlano del nulla con esattezza
pensate parlano del nulla con esattezza
e sempre più sempre più cupo sempre più
depresso sempre più solo finché arriva
al culmine
ed è questo l'attimo dell'esplosione
quindi un ascesa un ascesa di
depressione un ascesa di solitudine
nell'astrazione plastica nell'astrazione
con questi quadri che che che pulsano
che
battono che che vengono avanti si
contraggono visti dal vivo sono
incredibili veramente sembra di essere
al loro interno sembra di essere in un
teatro di colore finché arriva qua
finché arriva qui quindi io quello che
vi voglio dire oggi è che poi non è che
dovete seguire per forza pavarotti ma è
che quell urlo non significa l'aria più
familiare più famosa che noi conosciamo
che un quadro del genere non è mica
detto che vi debba piacere vi potete
interessare altro però è importante
riuscire a sfondare questo scetticismo è
importante riuscire a capire che questo
quadro significa un'evoluzione di un
artista che prima faceva il figurativo
sapete che picasso disse io a 4 anni
sapevo disegnare come raffaello ci ho
messo tutta la vita imparare a disegnare
come un bambino ed è esattamente questo
la semplificazione più totale in un
quadro che pulsa che pur se di colore è
la storia di un ragazzino russo che
emigra dalla russia negli stati uniti
dall attuale rettore negli stati uniti
vive solo a causa del fatto che nessuno
capisce che nell esaltazione delle
differenze che si manifesta la più alta
delle qualità dell'uomo vive isolato
vive alcolizzato vive sempre sull'orlo
del baratro vive fino a che decide di
togliersi la vita di suicidarsi
recidendosi le arterie di entrambe le
braccia vedi questo quadro rappresenta
questa storia rappresenta la storia di
un uomo che come scrissero il rolling
stone intenti black canzone che è stata
ispirata proprio dai quadri di rothko un
uomo che ha passato tutta la vita a
cercare di nascondere il sole dal cielo
[Musica]
[Applauso]